[Music]
question party is very simple
a bunch of viewers tweeted questions at
me and tarik and we're gonna answer some
of them right now
are you ready derek i'm ready okay
hampton stevens asked what was a
formative book for each of you when you
were growing up
ooh great question
um once when i was
five six five four something
uh i hurt my thumb really bad y'all and
i'm the youngest of five
so i get babied like a mug you can tell
by the way i behave
um and i hurt my thumb and i
thought for sure it was broken it was
all swollen i ganked it real good and my
sister
read james said the giant peach to me
while i was like oh
and then we read it every night until we
were done and it was very cute
that's the sweetest story yeah just a
giant beach what's yours
dracula dang it
i mean it was the first book like i
remember being really excited
like when it was like i was in you know
like i was reading encyclopedia brown
and stuff like that but that was like
the first like book
tarik i need to know what age you were
fourth or fifth grade god bless and i
did not
no did i not comprehend a lot of it
because so many of it is correspondence
letters
in like languages and romania but like i
remember like
i gotta get to the end of this i gotta
find out what happens um
i would say between that or ralph
ellison's invisible man in high school
which was given to me by the only one of
the only black teachers in my school mr
mason
oh and yeah that was super formative
so that's why tara gives tarik you said
dracula and shocked my balls off and
then went on to say this is not a bit
no okay you never know um and who knew
you would end up
in romania yes cheering for your goddamn
fearing for my damn life that was uh
uh and yeah the book did not prepare me
it did not
powerful week asked
if you could give each other one
superpower what would that be
i would give tarik the super power to
shut up
um i would give tarik the superpower of
um i guess to read people's minds
that'd probably be the most fun for who
tarek is
oh okay also it would if he could read
your mind
you wouldn't be like oh no something has
happened to tarik
you'd just be like oh you'd be like this
is just another aspect of who jerick is
it really goes in there well with the
personnel
over here okay okay it'd be like that oh
okay
uh chaos magic uh
wanda vision was a show that some people
watched i don't know if you watched it
but uh the character uh that wanda
she can basically manipulate reality and
she makes a whole sitcom a whole town
and i think if amber if you made like a
whole sitcom in town nobody would really
be upset about it we'd be having the
time of our lives it'd be a great time
i would be concerned with if you are
happy yeah
so i would get you hooked untrust
the best kidding i wouldn't but that
would make you happy
um you guys i did watch wanda vision and
the other day in a sketch i had to say i
hadn't seen it and it really hurt
same but i have seen it i've seen
everything
if it has a um comic book character in
it i've seen it
yeah okay juniper no this is taking a
long time
yeah i'm sorry no hey you guys you get
this [ __ ] is empty
i'm just how do you expect me to act i'm
gonna quote you from last week
we didn't come to their house you came
to our house
we live here you did this to you yeah
this is don't change the channel i'm
sorry
juniper nettles asked what was the first
cassette tape you
owned cassette tape okay first of all
judith
how the oh do you think i am
secondly it was um it was cool like that
oh because i'm cool like that i'm cool
like that
i'm cool like that that was my very
first like
i'm my own person and i like this and
i'm gonna take
my 99 cents or whatever it was and buy
my
single and play it for myself
i played it to death i am not cool like
that oh what was your first cassette
the best of al jarrow
oh my god when did you buy it
yesterday loved
al jarreau when i was a kid i loved it
any time a song of his came in the radio
we're in this love together
that was my [ __ ] and so i was like oh
this is on sale come on can i get this
you can get it
light bear is on the mind
has always been this he's like
a grown man but he was always this it
was just small
yeah same dude yeah you guys dog 925
asked who is the better dancer you or
tarek well i think what you want is for
us to get up and dance
but i'm not gonna do that i uh i damn
nearly gave myself a heart attack
earlier today we were dancing in the
groom because
justin was playing the best music in the
world so
my son works here his name is joseph
just in my calling my son because i love
him so bad
but uh we played the song how low can
you go
by ludacris it is the best song in the
world
yeah i mean it's certainly
i mean it's certainly out there i i hear
the song
the song how low can you go hits my ear
my common sense shuts off and then my
body is just possessed
yeah same and i know all the lyrics and
i don't know why
like outside of like i really enjoy the
song but i know
all the lyrics and uh yeah i you just go
ham in that song
just ugh so the answer is ludicrous
yeah luna chris wentz i know neither of
us can dance
you want some a dancer don't come over
here we'll have anything for you
we can have a good night we will we will
i'll have a good time
but look if if you're asking like if you
need that skip
i'm there for you
so hard because that's what you got to
do i'm there for the skip
you don't have to do that it's part that
hard
that's so high and let the rest of the
people do the electric slide but like
you've kicked several of them at that
point yeah well they need to make way
you guys that's all the time we have for
question party this was great
let's do it again okay derek you can't
be
get up as high as your face your foot
shouldn't be
here it should be down where feet are
[Music]
[Applause]
you